Brazil takes breast milk very seriously
it has over 200 milk banks nationwide
the highest of any country but here's
the weird part while the US has over one
and a half times the population of
Brazil it only has 24 milk banks which
distribute less than 6 million ounces of
breast milk a year and that's a serious
problem
since intensive care units alone demand
over 63 million ounces annually so
parents of healthy babies need to find
another way to feed their kids and we'll
turn to other more obscure sources of
course many parents have a built-in
supply of breast milk free of charge but
not everyone can breastfeed this might
be because they don't produce enough
milk on their own their work schedule
leaves little time for breastfeeding or
they simply don't have breasts in the
first place in fact
only an estimated 26 percent of North
Americans exclusively breastfed so if
you're short on breast milk many parents
will head to groups like human milk for
human babies which connects milk donors
with milk seekers in this case helping
over 20,000 community members in 52
countries but there's still not enough
milk to go around
that's where online marketplaces come in
on ad classified sites like only the
breast and breastfeeding moms unite
people sell their milk for around $2 an
ounce that's a bargain compared to over
$4 that milk banks will charge but this
is a case of you get what you pay for
because the milk you might receive may
not be a hundred percent human in a 2015
study for example researchers ordered
milk from an anonymous online market
they tested the contents of each sample
and discovered that one in every 10
samples was contaminated with cow's milk
and by a significant amount to the
contaminated samples contained about 10
percent cow's milk that's a lot more
than a few drops moreover a 2013 report
found that 74% of milk from online
markets contained harmful bacteria which
probably came from poor collection
storage or shipping all this begs the
why go through the hassle and risk when
you can easily grab some baby formula at
your local grocery well formula just
doesn't cut it
human breast milk is jam-packed with
brain developing nutrients disease
fighting antibodies that jumpstart the
immune system and helpful bacteria that
rev up the baby's own gut flora but baby
formula has no antibodies or bacteria
and that can make a huge difference
researchers calculated that over 800,000
formula-fed infants who die each year
worldwide could have been saved by
breastfeeding so parents are caught
between a rock and a hard place a
formula or mystery milk fun fact in
brazil the government funds couriers on
motorbikes to collect breast milk
directly from people's houses